ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียม
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธค่ะค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 6
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคม
ปีพตอะไรคะพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะขอสไตส์ญี่ 2022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอน
นี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูเรียมตอนนี้ 9:00 น 32
นาทีค่ะคุยอ่า
09:32 นาทีแล้วรู้สึกหิวข้าวจะเป็นยังไง
คะหิวข้าวนี่ครูหญิงชวนครูเรียมอัดวีดีโอ
เก้าโมงเช้านี้ผู้เรียนเดือดร้อนเหรอคะ
สร้างปัญหาให้ผู้เรียนเลยเหรอคะ
วิธี
ธรรมดาเร็วกินข้าวตอนนี้
ก็ผู้หญิงบอกว่ากูได้งามผู้หญิงไม่อยู่
ประเทศไทยนะกูเรียมเปลี่ยนเป็น 9:00 นที่
ประเทศไทยได้ไหมผู้เรียนก็ได้ต้องเดือด
ร้อนใช่ไหมเปลี่ยนเวลาใช่ต้องเปลี่ยนเวลา
กินข้าว
ต้องเลื่อนออกไปเป็น 10:00 น
ค่ะเอาผู้เดียวไว้ต้องอัดวีดีโอไปด้วยฉิว
ข้าวไปด้วยใช่ผู้หญิงคุยขอโทษค่ะผู้เรียน
มขึ้นขอโทษค่ะต้องให้ผู้เรียนเดือดร้อน
แบบนี้ผู้หญิงเคยทำให้คนอื่นเดือดร้อนอีก
ไหมคะเนี่ยอุ้ยผู้หญิงก็ให้จะอยากทำนะแต่
ว่าเขาไม่บอกไงหรอจะเรียบก็ทำนะทำบ่อย
แล้วก็มีคนบอกด้วยหรอกูเลี้ยงทำอะไรให้
ใครเดือดร้อนคะเตรียมชอบทำงานตอนกลางคืน
ค่ะแล้วพ่อพ่อกับแม่ของเดียวเขาก็จะนอน
ใช่ไหมทำนอนตอนกลางคืนตอนแบบคุณพ่อคุณแม่
ครูเรียมนอนกี่โมงอ่ะคะประมาณนอนประมาณ
กี่โมงพ่อกับแม่นอนประมาณ
22:00 นนอนเร็วที่ถูกใช้เตรียม 4 ทุ่ม
เนี่ยเริ่มทำงานค่ะเราเรียนก็ต้องเปิดไฟ
เงินไฟสว่างเลยแล้วก็ทำงานทำงานทำงานจน
ถึง 2:00 น
3:00 นอีกทีนะติ๊ง
แล้วแม่เรียมก็ตื่นขึ้นมาก่อนใครใครเปิด
ไฟ
แล้วก็ไม่ใช่เดินออกมาดูว่าเลี่ยมไปนอน
นอนดึกๆน่ะสมองสมองเนี่ยไม่ดีไปน้องๆเขา
ครูเรียมทำให้คุณทำให้พ่อกับแม่เดือดร้อน
ใช่นอนไม่ได้ใช่ไหมว่ากูเรียนเนี่ยเปิดไฟ
ทำงานตอนกลางคืนใช่ชายค่ะกรีไม่ใช่พ่อแม่
นะคะพลี
ให้คะทุเรียนทำให้ใครเดือดร้อนนี่คะจะทำ
งานตอนกลางคืนเวลาที่เดิมไปทำงานต่าง
จังหวัดเราก็จะมีโรงแรมใช่ไหม
สายค่ะเพราะว่าเราไม่มีบ้านเนาะบ้านของ
เราไม่ได้ก็ไม่ได้มีบ้านทุกจังหวัดนะคะ
ใช่แล้วพิมพ์ก็อาทำงานตอนกลางคืนนี่
เดี๋ยวก็อยู่ห้องนี้ใช่ไหมแล้วก็ผู้เรียน
ทำงานอะไรตอนกลางคืนหมายถึงว่าถ้าที่บ้าน
เข้าใจได้สมัยเปิดไฟคุณพ่อคุณแม่เดือด
ร้อนนอนไม่ได้แต่ถ้าที่โรงแรมครูเรียม
อยู่คนเดียวใช่ไหมที่โรงแรมใช่
ไม่มีใครเดือดร้อนสิเพราะกูเรียนอยู่คน
เดียวห้องที่อยู่ข้างๆอุ้ย
เขาจะมีห้องที่อยู่ข้างๆเนี่ยอันนี้เรียน
ณห้องที่อยู่ข้างๆ
เตรียมทำงานใช่ไหมคะเรียงก็ทำงานบันทึก
เสียง
อันร้อนวีดีโอเหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะวีดีโอ
เล่นก็พูดพูดสวัสดีค่ะยินดีต้อนรับค่ะ
แล้วก็พูดผู้แต่งใหม่น่ะพูดๆไหมเออเสียง
ก็ดังเนาะสีดำมากห้องก็หยุดติดกัน
เสือ
ครูผู้หญิงหาตอน 2:00 น 3:00 น
2:00 น 3:00 นขอข้างๆเขาก็แบบเคาะเคาะ
ผนัง
ห้องครัวเรียนเหรอคะ
แล้วก็พูดอะไรไว้ไม่พูดเป็นพูดอย่างเฮ้ย
มีคนนอนอยู่ห้องข้างๆ
คนหรือเปล่าใช่ตอนแรกคิดว่าของๆของไม่มี
ใครนอนหรอกเป็นโรงแรมเดี๋ยวก็อาจจะอยู่
ห้องอื่นแหละแต่ว่าห้องข้างๆไม่มีก็เลย
เปิดทำงานงานทำงานทำงานทำงานประมาณ 3:00
น
มีคนอยู่ห้องข้างๆ
เขาเดือดร้อนเขานอนไม่ได้
ก็เลยเคาะ
เสียงดังมาแล้วจะนอน
ปิดๆคอมเพอร์ฟอร์ปิดทุกอย่างนอนเราก็ทำ
ให้เดือดร้อนไปแล้ว
ใช่เพราะว่าแบบผู้หญิงไปนอนโรงแรมมาหาโรง
แรมเขาน่าจะแบบต้องเงียบมากๆอ้ะเพราะเขา
มีเหมือนมีมีใครๆแบบเป็นกระดาษเป็นป้าย
อย่างเงี้ยติดเอาไว้ที่ห้องว่า
ห้ามปาร์ตี้ตอนตั้งแต่หน้าจอเวลาประมาณ
10:00 น
10:00 นเป็นต้นไปมั้งตั้งแต่ 10:00 นไป
อ่ะค่ะห้ามปาร์ตี้ห้ามเสียงดัง
เพราะว่าคิดว่าจะทำให้ห้องอื่นๆเนี่ย
เดือดร้อนไม่เขาจะนอนไม่ได้ไงครับผมห้าม
ห้ามปาร์ตี้หญิงไม่เคยเห็นไงไม่เคยเห็น
ที่โรงแรมไหนแบบมีป้ายก็คือไปติดเอาไว้
ว่าห้ามปาร์ตี้
อาจจะมีคนไปแล้วแบบปาร์ตี้กันคุยกันเสียง
ต่างๆชนแก้ว
ท้ายๆๆแต่ว่านี่นี่ครูเรียมครูหญิงอ่ะ
อยู่คอนโดมิเนียมใช่ไหมคะที่กรุงเทพฯ
Condominium เนี่ยเขาก็จะเหมือนกับมี
ป้ายติดเอาไว้ว่าถ้าถามสูบบุหรี่
คือแบบที่คอนโดมันจะมีระเบียงอ่ะระเบียง
ออกไปข้างนอกค่ะว่าอันนี้เป็นเป็นห้องของ
เราใช่ไหมดูนักเรียนจะเห็นก่อนลบก่อนนะคะ
ตัวนี้เป็นตึกอ่ะ
เสนอเป็นตึกคอนโดวนะแต่เวลานักเรียนมอง
มาตรงนี้มันจะมีเหมือนเป็นระเบียงออกมา
มันจะยื่นออกมาค่ะจะยื่นออกมาข้างนอกๆ
ระเบียงตรงเนี้ยทุกห้องไม่มีใช่ไหมมันจะ
มีอย่างนี้ติดๆกันอันนี้ห้องครูหญิงอัน
นี้ห้องมิสเตอร์ a  here ถ้าคนนี้สูบ
บุหรี่
ควันเนี่ยมันก็จะมาห้องครูหญิงผู้หญิงก็
เดือดร้อนเขาก็จะติดป้ายไว้เลยว่าห้ามสูบ
บุหรี่
ข้ามเสียงดังห้ามเลี้ยงหมาเลี้ยงแมว
ว่าหมาแมวนะมันจะพุ่งๆมันจะเห่าคนอื่นที่
อยู่เนี่ยเขาก็เดือดร้อน
ใช่เพราะว่าหมาอาจจะหาตอนกลางคืนหรือว่า
เฮาตอนกลางวันก็ได้นะเขาก็มึงคนบางคนน่ะ
ทำงานเวลานะไม่เหมือนกันบางคนทำงานตอน
กลางวันแล้วก็นอนตอนกลางคืนในขณะนั้นคุณ
ก็ทำงานตอนกลางคืนคะ
แล้วก็นอนตอนกลางวันหนึ่ง
ถ้าเกิดได้ยินเสียงหมาเห่าโอ๋โอ๋
แต่เช้าเลยกูก็เดือดร้อนไม่ได้ไหมนอนไม่
ได้นี่มีพี่หนึ่งคนเขาเคยเล่าให้ฟังนะคะ
ครูเรียมว่าเมื่อก่อนน่ะเขาอยู่
คอนโดมิเนียมขึ้นบ่มีเนี่ยเนี่ยต้องเวลา
ทำอะไรต้องต้องคิดนะถ้าอยู่บ้านยังโอเค
แล้วนะแต่ถ้าคอนโดมิเนียมเนี่ยต้องคิดถ้า
เราผู้หญิงอัดวีดีโอตอนกลางคืนแล้วถ้าพูด
เสียงดัง
ห้องอื่นๆโอเคไหมเขานอนได้ไหมเราจะทำเขา
เดือดร้อนไหม
หวีนี้อย่างเนี้ยเมื่อก่อนผู้หญิงก็จะพูด
เบาๆสวัสดีค่ะเพราะว่าผู้หญิงไม่รู้ว่า
ข้องผู้หญิงได้ยินห้องอื่นไงเวลามีคนเดิน
มาแล้วเขาก็ไขกุญแจผู้หญิงก็ได้ยินถึงก็
คิดถ้ากูหญิงพูดเสียงดังนี้
4 ห้องห้องห้องอื่นนอนได้ไหมเขาจะเดือด
ร้อนหรือเปล่ากล้องกับเมื่อก่อนมีมีพี่
เขาเล่าให้ฟังนะคะบุเรียมเขาบอกว่าเขา
อยู่ Condominium ไม่ใช่มั้ยมันเป็น
คอนโดมิเนียมที่ไทยนะค่ะชนโดย William
ที่ไทยอ่ะค่ะมันสูงว่าช่วยมันจะมีชั้น
ชั้นๆหลายๆชั้นรถชั้น 1 ชั้น 2  S พี่คน
เนี้ยเขาอยู่ที่ชั้น 3 เรื่อง 3 แล้วก็
บอกว่าบางครั้งเนี่ยชั้น 4 เนี่ยก็จะมี
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงที่เขาทำงานตอนกลางคืนนะ
ค่ะทำงานตอนกลางคืนแล้วก็ประมาณเนี้ย 4:00
น
ตี 4 เนี่ยเขาก็จะกลับมาที่ห้องชั้น 4
แล้วก็ตำส้มตำ
แล้วอันเนี้ย
แต่ฉันสาวแล้วก็ชั้น 4 ชั้น 4 ตำส้มตำ
ชั้น 3 นอนเนี่ยโป่งตรงๆๆเดือดร้อนไว้ฮะ
นี้อันนี้ถือว่าทำให้คนอื่นเดือดร้อนและ
ตำส้มตำตอนตี 4 หรือว่าตีสองตี 2 ตำส้มตำ
คนอื่นเดือดร้อนไหมผู้หญิงทำให้เรียนหรอ
เธอไม่เรียนไม่ถึงตัวเลนส์เองทำไมครับ
ตอนตึกตอนตีสองเหรอแค่ 2 คู่ 2 ทุ่ม
ok นะ
แล้วรีบอยู่ชั้น 2 ทางที่อยู่มหาลัยใช่
ก็จะมี 1  2  3 ชั้นห้องเรียนอยู่
ข้างบนค่ะแล้วทีนี้เขาจะมีโทรศัพท์นะ
โทรศัพท์เบอร์โทรในตึกนี่แหละ
ห้องข้างล่างเขาก็โทรขึ้นมาหาห้องเรียน
ทั้งบนบอก
ทำอะไรหรอ
ทำอะไรหรอตำส้มตำใช่ไหมได้ยินเสียงลงมา
ข้างล่าง
นี่ก็เลยเลี้ยงเลยบอกมามากินมากินส้มตำนะ
คะ
แล้วก็โอเคมั้ยเขาก็โอเคหลังจากนั้นแล้ว
ก็เลยเป็นเพื่อนกันเขาก็เลยแบบซื้อซื้อ
มะละกอซื้อซื้อผักซื้อกับข้าวมาให้เรียน
ทำกับข้าวให้กินห้อง
เห็นไหมก็ดีนะทำให้คนอื่นเดือดร้อนสุด
ท้ายก็เป็นเพื่อนกันได้เพื่อนใหม่เลยให้
ผู้หญิงแต่ถ้าเกิดเดือนต่ำส้มตำตอนตี 2
อ่ะ
คิดว่าไม่โอเคนะ
ไม่ได้เป็นเพื่อนกันก็คงจะได้เจอเธอฉัน
ร้องกันว่าง่ายใช่ๆ
ผู้หญิงทำให้เรียนรู้เลยว่าฟิล์มก็สร้าง
ความเดือดร้อนให้คนอื่นๆเยอะมากๆอุ้ยผู้
เรียนน่ะเวลาเมื่อก่อนน่ะก็เป็นครูสมัย
สอนนักเรียนเป็นชาวต่างชาติอ่ะคะไม่ใช่คน
ไทยแล้วพอเขาไม่อยู่คอนโดมิเนียมที่มีคน
ไทยอยู่ด้วยอะเค้าก็ไม่เข้าใจไงบางครั้ง
อ่ะคนไทยทำอาหารอาหารไทยอ่ะมันมีกลิ่นใช่
คือผู้หญิงอ่ะโอเคนะอย่างคอนโดมิเนียมกู
หญิงอ่ะคะบางครั้งเนี่ยเปิดประตูออกมาอืม
หอม
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยโอเคไม่มีปัญหาครูหญิงไม่รู้
สึกเดือดร้อนถ้าห้องอื่นทำอาหารว่าบาง
ครั้งเนี่ยผู้หญิงก็คิดไม่ออกใช่ไหมว่า
เอ๊วันนี้จะกินอะไรดีนะมีแต่พอห้องข้างๆ
ห้องผู้หญิงใช่ไหมแล้วก็ห้องข้างๆทำอาหาร
หอม
ผักบุ้งคุยก็คิดวันนี้กินผัดผักบุ้งละกัน
เลยแม่นๆเดินเดินออกไปเคาะห้องข้างๆก็ชอบ
หยาบสมกินด้วยเหรอ
ใช่ผู้หญิงไม่รู้สึกเดือดร้อนนะแต่แบบนัก
เรียนน่ะควรต่างชาติพ่อเขามาอยู่กับคนไทย
แล้วแบบทำไมคนไทยทำอาหารแล้วก็มีกลิ่นไม่
ได้ไม่โอเค
ใช่เขาเดือดร้อนไงเขารู้สึกกลิ่นมันเข้า
มาที่ห้องของเขาเขาก็คิดทำไมคนไทยไม่คิด
ถึงคนอื่นเลยเขาเดือดร้อนใช่ไหมแต่เรารู้
สึกแต่ผู้หญิงเนี่ยเป็นคนไทยไม่เป็นไร
โอเคไม่เดือดร้อน
ที่เราทำอะไรไปอ่ะแต่มันอาจจะไม่ได้เดือด
ร้อนทันทีนะอย่างเช่นเวลาที่เราแบบเดิมๆ
เดินไปแล้วแบบเศษเศษ tissue  tissue
เนี่ยเราใช้น้ำมันร่วงร่วงลงพื้นหรือว่า
พลาสติกที่แท็บร่วงลงพื้นแล้วที่นี้เวลา
ที่
มันเป็นร่วงลงพื้นแล้วเขาจะมีท่อระบายน้ำ
ค่ะพี่
ไวน์น้ำตรงเนี้ยรอบพลาสติกมันไปอยู่ตรง
เนี้ยโอแล้วถ้าสนตกล่ะฝนตก
น้ำก็จะไหลลงท่อระบายน้ำไม่ได้อุ้ย
น้ำแล้วจะยังไงอ่ะ
เหมือนที่กรุงเทพฯเป็นอยู่ในกันฝนตกลงมา
น้ำก็จะท่วมไส้เดือดร้อนเพราะว่า
คนกรุงเทพฯในราคาเดือดร้อนคนที่มีบ้านมี
อพาร์ทเม้นท์มี Condominium ทำผมอยู่
กรุงเทพฯฝนตกทีไรเดือดร้อนทุกที
น้ำท่วม
ผู้หญิงรู้
กูเรียนไม่คุยไม่รู้ว่ากูเรียนเห็นหรือ
เปล่าค่ะ BTS  BTS เขาเขามีป้ายบอกว่าผู้
หญิงที่ที่มัดผม
สมัครมัดผมและเวลาขึ้น BTS เนี่ยต้อง
ระวังผมเพราะว่าถ้าเราจะบัตรผมแรงๆเนี่ย
ผมโดนคนอื่นคนอื่นเขาเดือดร้อน
ทำให้คนอื่นเดือดร้อนพิมพ์ก็
ใช่หรอกสวัสดิ์ผมมันผู้หญิงนี่ลำบากเนาะ
ต้องทำมีอะไรเวลาอยู่บน BTS ต้องอยู่แบบ
ไหนหรออย่างงี้หรอกคือเวลาที่เราจะหมุน
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยให้แบบให้ให้ให้ดูเตือนตัว
เองด้วยมันจะทำให้คนอื่นเดือดร้อน
รู้แสดงว่าอยู่ใน BTS ต้องมีคนคนคนเยอะ
มากๆแล้วก็ยืนให้กันว่า
หูแล้วแต่กูเรียนบางคนเขาสะบัดผมแรงจริงๆ
นะเจ็บนะ
เจ็บมันเจ็บนะ
เราต้องมีคนไปบอกแม่เลยบอก BT เองใช่
เดือดร้อนผมผู้หญิงนะสะบัดแรกๆอ้ะ
ใช่เขา
บอกว่า BTS เนี่ยเขาบอกว่ามีคนเดือดร้อน
เยอะก็เลยส่งเหมือนส่งข้อความเหมือนคล้าย
ๆแบบก็ไม่ได้เป็นคอมเพลนอ่ะนะบอก BTS ว่า
เออเนี่ยผู้หญิงที่สะบัดผมแรงๆเนี่ยทำเขา
เดือดร้อน
อุ้ย
ชายกับแม่เวลามั้ยไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่บ้านไม่ใช่
ของของเราใช่ไหมค่ะนะฉันมาเรียมาอยู่บ้าน
ตัวเอง
พ่อแม่ยังเดือดร้อนเลยเห็นไหมใช่อยู่ที่
ไหนเดือดร้อยคนที่
ระบบ BTS ไม่ใช่บ้านของเราใช่ไหมมี S
[เพลง]
ขนาดขับรถออกไปข้างนอกยังเดือดร้อนคนอื่น
เลยค่ะอุ้ยทำไมหาเกิดร้อนอะไรโคเรียม
กุญแจรถดั้
กุญแจรถแบบนี้ใช่ไหมกับเรียมทำมันร่วงลง
ท่อระบายน้ำ
อันนี้ท่อระบายน้ำเวลาฝนตกใช่มั้ยน้ำก็จะ
ไหลลงท่อระบายน้ำ
เตรียมทำกุญแจตกลงข้อระบายน้ำค่ะ
เอานักเรียนยังไงอ่ะรถอ่ะ
เลี้ยวลื่นโทรบอกโทรบอกที่บ้านแม่ไม่มี
กุญแจอีกอันนึงไหมเอามาให้เรียนหน่อย
แล้วเลี้ยงอยู่ที่ไหนยังอยู่ที่ร้านร้าน
อาหารมากินข้าวตอนนี้อะไรไหมกลับบ้านดี
มาก
งู
กลับบ้านแรง
แม่ก็ต้องเดือดร้อนใช่ The ร้อนเอากุญแจ
มาให้
งูแม่เดินมาใช่ไหมคะแม่ต้องขับรถมาแล้วก็
น่าเออ
เลย
เดือดร้อนไหมคะผู้หญิงควรตัวอยู่คนเดียว
ไหม
ใช่คนจะอยู่คนเดียวนะอยู่คนเดียวก็ตำส้ม
ตำก็ห้องข้างล่างเดือดร้อนเอง
มันก็บอกว่าอยู่เฉยๆเลี้ยงอยู่เฉยๆไม่ทำ
อะไรเลยจะได้ไม่มีถ้าไม่เดือดร้อน
หล่อถ้าเกิดยืนอยู่เฉยๆนะพ่อแม่ก็ต้องหา
ข้าวมาให้เรียนกินดิเออทุเรียนไว้ทำงาน
ไม่มีเงินพ่อแม่ก็ต้องเดือดร้อน
เออ
ทำไมเกิดมาแบบสร้างความเดือดร้อนเยอะขนาด
นี้เราเกิดมาเราก็สร้างความเดือดร้อนให้
พ่อแม่แล้วนะพ่อแม่มาคอยดูแลเรา
แต่ถ้ากูเรียนแบบเราเรียนหนังสือหรือไม่
โอเคอย่างเงี้ยคุณครูเกาะฮัลโหลหญิงเรียน
หนังสือไม่ดีเลยพ่อแม่ก็ต้องเดือดร้อน
ไปโรงเรียนเห็นไหม
แบบนี้นักเรียนของเราเคยทำอะไรให้ใคร
เหลือเดือดร้อนมั้ยชายหรือว่าเคยมีใครทำ
อะไรให้นักเรียนเดือดร้อนไหม
หนูนักเรียนก็ Comment และก็ได้นะคะแต่
ว่าอยู่ประเทศไทยแล้วเจออะไรที่เดือดร้อน
ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้คนไทยทำอะไรให้นัก
เรียนเดือดร้อนใดๆกับแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้
เนี่ยผู้หญิงจะไม่ทำให้คุณเรียนเดือดร้อน
แล้วให้กูเรียนไปกินข้าวยังมีความสุขก็
แล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะ
ได้เลยค่ะวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนนะคะถ้าใจ
ขนาดไว้บายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ